[Music]
tear gas and water cannon across Europe
and growing anger over coronavirus
restrictions in Athens Greek police
tried to break up protests against
compulsory covid-19 vaccinations some in
the crowd threw petrol bombs the police
responded with tear gas
the rally outside the Greek Parliament
was the third this month against
mandatory inoculations for some workers
including Healthcare and nursing staff
this is not an anti-vaccine movement
these are people that have thought about
it and want their freedom
the mood was the same at a demonstration
in Paris their tear gas filled the air
as protesters opposed to a government
virus pass faced off against Riot police
this was just one of dozens of mainly
peaceful rallies across the country
which brought out more than 160 000
people
The Fringe plan requires all health care
workers be vaccinated and for everyone
else to prove their virus or vaccination
status in order to enter restaurants and
other cultural venues
we need to wait a little bit before the
French people can decide I feel we're
being rushed it's only been six months
since these vaccines were made available
and it feels like the French people are
being forced with blackmail I think a
part of France is always going to be
unwilling and blackmail and threats
won't work
I think systematic vaccination is too
extreme and too risky and I'm also very
shocked by the extension of this to
children I think they have nothing to
gain and we are taking too many risks to
try and save our elders
a similar proposal sparked protests in
neighboring Italy where people chanted
down with the dictatorship from August a
vaccination certificate will be needed
to eat in restaurants and visit Cinemas
on Thursday the EU reported that 200
million Europeans have now been fully
vaccinated more than half of the adult
population but that figure falls short
of the Block's 70 Target set for the
summer
[Music]
in the United Kingdom thousands of
people rallied in London against what
they say is the erosion of civil
liberties after the government's track
and trace app meant more than 600 000
people were told to isolate at home
earlier this month
the coronavirus pandemic is far from
over and neither it's the debate about
how to reopen economies while keeping
everybody safe and happy Alexia Brian Al
Jazeera